[Music]
[Music]
eminem's daughter haley jade is his
biggest fan
already mom's spaghetti the rapper's 26
year old daughter was at super bowl 56
in l.a on sunday to support her famous
dad who performed alongside dr dre snoop
dogg mary j blige kendrick lamar and
surprise guest 50 cent and anderson pack
during the pepsi halftime show
[Music]
the grammy winner brought down the house
with a special rendition of his
oscar-winning song lose yourself and
haley was right there in the stands
posting clips of her dad's performance
on her insta story
the michigan state alum also shared this
snap from her seat alongside a cheeky
caption here for the halftime show
staying for stafford of course stafford
being los angeles rams quarterback
matthew stafford leading up to her trip
the michigan native revealed an awkward
moment she had at the nail salon on
tick-tock
so the lady at the nail salon is
checking me out and she goes
have a good trip
and i go
you too
so
looks like i'll be finding a new nail
salon now and before her dad took the
stage she documented her excitement as
she headed into the stadium
[Music]
eminem capped off his part of the
halftime show by taking a knee which
appeared to show a sign of solidarity
with nfl players who have used the
gesture as a sign of protest most
famously by colin kaepernick reports
quickly surfaced that the nfl told the
musician not to take a knee but a
spokesperson for the organization denied
that claim telling e.t in a statement
quote we watched every rehearsal this
week and that element was included
adding players and personnel members
could have taken a knee today so there
would have been no reason to tell a
performer he or she could not for
whatever reason
this year's super bowl marked the first
time that hip-hop took center stage
during halftime and haley wasn't the
only one who loved it in fact buster
rhymes told e.t that the whole thing
made him emotional proud of tears of joy
though like that i'm able to actually
live and witness
something so grand and so
superb and such a phenomenal evolution
for our culture and for entertainment
overall lady gaga tweeted that the show
was a quote bomb of radical love missy
elliott called it legendary while lebron
james said it was the greatest halftime
show he'd ever seen just what is the
feeling
just relieved
thrilled
numb
feeling like
you saw something was part of something
that's truly historic e.t spoke with
super bowl halftime show executive
producer jessie collins backstage
immediately after the show wrapped and
he opened up about the musician's
profound impact oh that it is everyone
is in tears because you know that
you know dre changed music
go back to nwa he made the world look at
the west coast and what they were saying
and then he has continued to change it
over and over again eminem 50 cent it
goes on and on kendrick snoop it's like
he keeps keeps changing music changing
music for the world
[Music]
you